ah ah
[Musique]
les aventures de la seconde guerre
mondiale berlin sous les bombes des
alliés des soldats nazis à tous les
coins de rue n'est ce pas le meilleur
endroit où atterrir pour nos personnages
elliott le robot iris la voyageuse
temporel et thomas le dôme à quoi se
rapproche des traces du docteur simon
portées disparues
pétain devient site merde
ouais je comprends mieux pourquoi tu
étais pas très emballé par cette époque
parce que c'est la guerre fuyons la zone
de combat ils ont tout et comme dans
call of duty n'ont pas été vraiment
qu'on attendait faut que je fasse un
truc avec ma robe là c'est hyper chiant
pour se déplacer hop tu vas trop le goût
de faire la haie raccourci mois l'europe
ok ouais ok d'accord attentes et sérieux
c'est beaucoup trop court je sais pas
dans les mangas c'est la longueur
normale
maintenant ce sera plus pratique pour te
déplacer pour mater mon cul ouais
or il me reste plus qu'à changer de
pompe ah bah tiens je vais prendre celle
de monsieur là elles seront un peu
grande maison va le faire et ce sont les
chaussures d'un soldat mort 2001 et
maintenant c'est les miennes ah bah
voilà dit mieux le diadème de rennes sur
ta tête bateau genève a non non ça je le
garde
trouve-t-il et là les intrus wauquiez
vous moi c'est thomas chers soldats
on s'est perdus sur le champ de bataille
nous sommes berlinois nous parlons
parfaitement allemand
vous entendez non mais moi je parle pas
du tout un seul mot génial et vous avez
raison
entre allemands et parfait rien à faire
ici la ville est à feu et à sang allez
vous mettre à l'abri nous avons entendu
je parle très bien elles vont en fait je
pense pas du tout je possède un
traducteur actifs qui traduit toutes les
langues dans un large périmètre
c'est pour ça que le solde à penser
qu'on parlait allemand n'était pas
demander pourquoi les onglets te parler
en français tout à l'heure tu es pas en
grande forme on est cuit au pays de
galles
aso en france et au royaume uni et
france gall alors portons nous suis dit
quelque chose c'est la voleuse de ma
machine un oui ça me revient à énorme
rond moi ma machine retrouvons-nous
d'amyris encore de la sorcellerie
sans nous en enfer non nous sommes à
berlin reprenez les machines salle
voleuse mais c'est vous qui avez volé
mon trône avec votre sort c'est l'allié
nord et si cet objet que vous convoitez
taylor alors je le gardais peut-être que
vous
à lacaune à sa mort est partie elle est
repartie avec ma machine
j'avais une chance sur combien pour
qu'elle apparaisse devant nous 100%
la machine est programmé pour revenir à
son propriétaire la machine est en mode
shuffle elle voyage aléatoirement dans
le temps et l'espace
mais votre bien finir par revenir et là
paf on récupère ma [ __ ] de machines
j'ai bien compris mais ça marche
d'ailleurs iris qu'est ce que tu faisais
dans un château on est obligé d'en
parler maintenant
j'aime bien voyager moi aussi j'aime
bien voyager mais quand je vais en
espagne je cherche pas à devenir le pape
c'est au vatican bon j'aime bien voyager
dans le temps
mon père a inventé cette machine alors
ça fait un an que je change d'époque
pour découvrir le monde comment
t'expliquer imagine que je suis en
erasmus temporel la trace des docteurs
six mois est très faible
c'est très difficile de le localiser
nerfs d'un ça nous arrange pas du tout
ça on est comme des cons sous les
bombardements des américains excusez moi
tu as par leur baisse les yeux c'est un
petit garçon qu'est ce que tu fais ici
mon chou c'est dangereux il ya des
bombes qui tombent du ciel
je suis perdu je cherche mes parents ou
les as tu vu pour la dernière fois dans
un train j'étais avec mes parents et mon
peuple attend tu viens d'où exactement
pas de france on est montés dans un
train la sncf était gentil c'était
gratuit emmerdes un champ suprend gratos
n'ont pas la chance du tout non toute
une famille dans un train en direction
l'est dans les années 40
ça te rappelle rien vu comme tu le dis
ça de vrai le loukouss thomas c'est dans
call of duty mais je regarde pas les
cinématiques pour ça comment j'ai pu
sortir avec toi bon écoute menti on sait
pas où sont des parents mais reste prêt
nous tu serais plus en sécurité
je vais retrouver ma famille le risque
qu'il soit encore en vie et proche de 6
et wii vont bien ils vont bien chez les
rssi vous êtes gentil pour comme le
monsieur tout à l'heure ah oui fais
attention soldats ils peuvent être très
méchants envers eux toi et
tout peut plus c'est un monsieur bizarre
avec une blouse blanche qui est apparu
comme par magie me poser des questions
et après il m'a laissé tout seul ici ça
ressemble à la description du docteur
simon était enfant est-ce que c'est lui
oui c'est ça c'est mon père génial on va
pouvoir leur trouver intéressant ton
père abandonne les enfants juifs
oui va ça va il avait la tête ailleurs
enfin je crois
alors dit nous ils allaient les
messieurs la barre d'un cran bâtiment
avec les grandes croire très bien c'est
un qg basique
rendons-nous là bas super allons je suis
pas sûr que ce soit l'endroit idéal pour
toi est d'accord donc on le laisse sous
les bombes alors oui bon ça va allez
viens petit reste avec nous du titre
this way we made and avec un peu de
chance mon père est encore là bas au
début il était très gentil comme vous et
après il était méchant il m'a frappée
durant une enfance difficile et les 110
mon petit il t'a fait des attouchements
dit quoi mon père ne ferais jamais ça
pour tous on y arriver cachez-vous
derrière et des prix pourquoi mon père
est venu dans un qg nazis sa veste et de
soldats allaient y en a partout où il va
pouvoir retrouver sa famille dans les
cieux crétins c'est tellement triste ans
le gamin est en train de discuter avec
les soldats
prennent dans leurs bras ah oui mais
soldats la mission santo
il fait du cadam passe très bien pour
lui elvire d'eau très bien mon petit
lucien il vous pouvez entrer faites
comme chez vous on est de la même
famille dont je pense pas qu'on soit de
la plus y 1 va retrouver des parents
qu'ils sont dans le bus mais ne va pas
déranger tapis il est une réunion très
importante en très cher ami hitler
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir aidé à retrouver mais
par le petit et tu viens d'où exactement
en france de la capitale paris vichy
mais il fait quoi ton papilles il est
maréchal c'est le maréchal pétain
vous connaissez [ __ ] si seulement
j'avais qui s'applique du coup mon petit
fils est pas juif
il m'apporte quoi marassi supérieur à va
nickel on est tombé sur un enfant nazis
bon écoute lucien pétain les hommes sont
tous égaux n'y a pas de race supérieure
mais non c'est par lucien dit pas de
bêtise la kippa des bêtises
en attendant moi je sais où il est le
monsieur avec la blue c'est vrai dit non
à l'heure dite la race aryenne et
supérieur et je vous dis oui il est très
bien la race aryenne
ian ne dit pas n'importe quoi il suffit
de dire ça et nous donne l'information
on dira jamais ça non sira sinon c'est
vous les nuls
vous serez jamais que le monsieur il
allait dans la bibliothèque oubliez ça
la bibliothèque ne partait pas garde
d'enfants ces deux familles ont des
rêves tes conneries
déjà que j'aime pas les enfants mais
alors les enfants d'asie casson nous
avant que les gardes débarquer la
bibliothèque et l étage que le dr simon
se trouve peut-être encore
[Musique]
la porte de la bibliothèque
thomas tu fais quoi 1 je me rends coiffe
c'est ou non mais c'est pour faire bonne
impression enfin j'ai passé ton père
quand même un moment faut être un peu
présentables on semble thomas alors
c'était pas du tout pour te du tout et
c'était juste or en l'air au cours des 7
rue dans ma bibliothèque à hitler ton
père c'est hitler commence à adolf
hitler et le père d'iris pas du tout
mais alors pas du tout c'est asa oui en
allemagne en 1944 on peut tomber sur
hitler
c'est un fait mais nos personnages sera
projeté ou s'éloignent team du docteur
sim au chaud froid siècle
vous n'allez pas le croire mais moi je
ne sais pas si vous êtes au courant
on savait que je savais
merci d'avoir écouté le troisième
épisode de l'épopée temporel n'hésite
pas à ta bonnet et à mettre un pouce en
l'air et à la semaine prochaine